the patriots quarterback to take the
first snap this year courtesy of points
bet cam newton minus 300 favorite that
means you got to bet 300 to win 100. mac
jones plus 350. jared stidham plus 900.
i'm going to feel you jared stiderman
you're gonna be on the roster he might
not be right but uh uh that that that
makes sense cam's the guy i feel like
cam's the guy
until he's injured or up you know maybe
they do some revolving door like they
did last year with cam newton and jared
stidham but but but cam's the guy to at
least start the season i think so 100
cam is the guy you know mac jones as
much as he's nfl ready coming from nick
saban smart and awesome pocket passer
and all the you know comparisons to
brady and everything like that still you
know i new england's not the type they
don't start they just listen i don't
think they're going to start a rookie
quarterback the week week one i just
don't think that's in their dna i think
they're fine with like hey cam newton
he's got a base of this offense we got
some talent around him this year and
they're gonna
you know continue to teach mac jones
this offense which we have talked about
is very complicated so i i totally
envision it being cam newton
what's your over under on cam newton's
starts this year i think we asked tom
curran about that right after mack jones
was drafted on pftpm but but what's your
over under uh cam newton starts versus
mac jones starts i i'm gonna go like
i'm going cam newton starts the whole
year unless he just gets hurt i don't
think we're gonna see mack jones this
year i don't think new england cares
they're going to sit him on the bench
and let him learn football and they got
cam newton and they're going to try to
kind of build on what they got
from what they got out of him last year
and the way they played and they'll see
where it goes you know again i don't
think like new england's in any pressure
here they're going to play this out you
know okay wait cam newton played really
well
okay great we'll keep him another gear
and mac jones sits on the bench for one
more year i mean again i think that's a
a real possibility if camden plays well
and i'm expecting cam newton to play
well one their team's gonna be good and
i i i don't think he's gonna fall into
that little you know crapola form he did
last year of throwing the football where
he fell apart for a few weeks
well i think covert had something to do
with it definitely as time has gone by
it's become more and more clear once he
got that case of covet he denied having
some brain fog but if you have brain fog
how aware are you that you have brain
fog so
go you know go figure out that conundrum
um i i
i hesitate to say this because
this is the time of year where we
talk about how teams are going to do
and we don't factor in
the reality
the probability that guys are going to
get injured and you know when you say
cam newton's going to start all 17 games
i see there's no way he's going to start
all 17 games and i feel bad saying that
yeah i hear you at some point he at some
point he's going to be physically unable
for whatever reason an ankle a shoulder
a concussion a neck a back a hip a thigh
a wing whatever it is he's not going to
be available to play
and and i hate and i hate to say that
but
you know this isn't your typical
franchise quarterback
suits up and plays every game of the
year and i think for that reason alone i
don't believe he's going to play the
whole scene no i mean listen i i hear
you i mean i did say that you maybe you
didn't hear me i just said yo unless he
gets injured i just i think it'll be 17
but i hear you i don't want to say
unless he is getting injured well he
didn't get injured last year
if he didn't he didn't he never played
every game other than the covid games so
i i just throw that out there yep okay
that made you pause and think for a
second but i know you're right it's a
very real thing and that's why 32 is not
32 for cam newton as compared to other
quarterbacks because the way he's played
and everything like that um so
i know that that's uh mike i mean listen
if you made me bet money i would bet
you're probably right on that one yes
and i don't like saying that either
because we don't wish that on upon cam
newton for sure we're not we're not
wishing it on anybody we're not doing
our jobs we don't factor it in i mean
the reality is cam newton
is
arguably the most impressive physical
specimen i've ever witnessed in football
he is a giant and he is well
proportioned and he is athletic and he
is just he is he is a huge human being
and this gets back to the debates that
that raged remember the 2016 season the
opener the rematch of the panthers
broncos game from super bowl 50 to start
the season
cam newton got the crap beat out of him
in that game and they don't throw the
flag and they don't throw the flag they
don't throw the flag because they see
this giant i agree you see all the
lilliputians bouncing off of him and
you're thinking
he's fine and he's thinking
i'm fine and the coaching staff that's
calling the running plays yeah he's fine
and then something breaks and and that's
i think that's the the the disconnect
that the patriots have maybe managed to
figure out how to to properly reconcile
even though you look at this guy and say
my god he's he's indestructible no
we've seen enough over the last 10 years
to know that he is destructible and you
have to factor that into how you use
them yeah and you know i i think they
they did factor that to what you're
saying too there was games where you
thought hey they're going to run him a
lot today i expect that and you didn't
really see him run much at all or no
quarterback design runs i think they
were wary of trying to keep his body
healthy and and still able to you know
perform at a high level but yes it's a
different animal when you're talking
about cam newton at the quarterback
position especially at the age of 32.
and i'm rooting for him i really am he's
been dealing with a lot and of course
the haters are all over the over him
because of last year and the fact the
way it looked with the patriots and of
course he went through such a bad
stretch throwing the football so he's
got a lot of a lot of critics he's got
to kind of wipe off his shoulders here
this year i i haven't told this story in
a while and in the event there's someone
out there who hasn't heard it before and
there's probably plenty of you my first
cam newton experience was walking down
6th avenue toward radio city music hall
2011 draft and they were walking guys on
the red carpet and i saw cam newton
and i thought oh they they had they're
on an elevated platform as they walk on
this red carpet as i got closer and
closer i realized there was no elevated
pop
a guy
is a giant and he was scared he just
head and shoulders above everyone and
that's how he is if you're on the
sideline of a football field he's
heading shoulders above everyone all
right
the the here's something that i'm
fascinated by because last year
as the season
approached we spent a lot of time trying
to figure out what the offense was going
to look like and my best information was
that josh mcdaniels was going to take
the offense he had devised for tim tebow
in denver but never got to use and used
that with cam newton in new england and
a lot of that came to fruition
how do you create a playbook
that has
cam newton and mac jones
both properly
coached up and ready
with plays that the the other players
are going to be able to to run because
it's almost like you need to have two
different playbooks one for newton and
one for jones yeah no that's that's
going to be a real aspect for their
football team it is yeah they're going
to mac jones is going to be more of the
traditional tom brady type of stuff now
you can work on all the movement stuff
right the fake the speed sweeps and all
that you know again mac jones did that
in college he was faking devante smith
here jalen waddle fake jewel you know so
you you could still do that that's part
of the football part of football now in
in 2021 but yes as far as some of the
run game stuff and all of that there's
going to be different rules for a cam
newton offense as compared to a mac
jones but nonetheless the game is never
just about hey the first and second down
runs and you know that's all there is to
it hey they're still going to have a lot
of drop back passes in the game plans
maybe it's not as you know
uh maybe the the the past plays that are
as intricate and deep in detail like
brady got to on page 452 in the offense
yeah that's not going to be available
for cam newton and mac jones but that's
okay i mean i still think mac jones is
going to get plenty of work with third
down passing nickel passing all of that
to where it's still a drop back pass
offense that works for him just yes when
he comes in the game there's not going
to be that running element or even
having to worry about that threat at all
the patriots son johnny smith hunter
henry a couple of very good tight ends
they have nelson aguilar and kendrick
bourne two new receivers which of the
new weapons do you think cam newton will
have the best connection with i'm going
to go with one of the tight ends and
johnny smith i i think so
they're just
i want to go with actually either one of
them now i really like aguilar and
bourne i think they'll really fit but
you know cam newton you know big the way
they run the ball and then new england
is just they're they're an old-school
team it goes back to like you know the
giants and phil sims and mark navarro
and that type of stuff they know how to
feature a tight end let alone tight ends
who were like you know dual threats good
at running and good at passing so i
think it's gonna be one of them you know
and i'm gonna err on jonu smith because
i think he'll be the guy that also gets
some of those short bootleg passes and
gets to run after the catch
and i think he'll just get a hair more
playing time because he's a little bit
more talented than hunter henry
and guys are in foxborough
despite the nfl pa's recommendation to
stay away from off season workouts
they're they're getting acquainted oh
yeah there's connections mike reese of
espn reported yesterday more than 50
players have you know it present through
the early stages of the offseason
program is this going to change people
and how they draft players see this is
where new england and all they're like
oh you know this guy's not as good as
this guy but this guy's personality test
and everything fits us more let's go
with them where sometimes we go oh man
they should have took that talented guy
here's the benefit of airing more on
what they do like we've talked about a
lot mike they got guys who are you know
all well what we're going to practice in
the parking lot up in canada today all
right coach i'll be there i'll see you i
mean that's what they have so these guys
are going to be there working why the
rest of the league is you know sipping
pina coladas on zoom calls
uh or pina coladas is the case whatever
they got i wonder i i wonder though well
you drink them every friday you should
know by now i wonder
at what point cause this whole back and
forth on off season workouts and you've
got tom brady coming out saying
negotiate directly with your coaches you
think bill belichick gives a crap about
any of that and at what point are we
going to have grievances filed against
coaches
who are believed to be pushing the guys
too hard you know it's never been an
issue there have been questions about
whether or not some of these workouts
are too intense i just wonder whether
that's the next frontier in this fight
coaches actually being on the wrong end
of grievances filed by players who say
that you're you're doing too much to
create the impression that these aren't
voluntary that you're working is too
hard and i i don't think anyone's ever
going to muster the nerve to do that to
bill belichick no it's you got to be
that's a
that's a slippery slope
very very slippery slope for the players
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports